you know my son got kicked out of a
Chinese buffet once no he ate too pretty
much so what he would do is around the
corner of the building was a Chinese
buffet and then he comes and he's
sitting there doing his work and stayed
there for hours doing his work and while
he's working he keeps going back and
forth eating and the guy goes new come
for lunch you stay for dinner you get
out and you go to give you guys some
money to let him come back in because he
loved the place you said you can
negotiate for anything we went to the
buffet at the Bellagio and my niece is
really 15 but I said she was 10. for
that price but that's smart dude
she don't eat much eats the same as a 10
year old it shouldn't go by the age it
should go by size you're a small person
and you eat light then you should be
charged by your weight damn it okay
ten times the price of buffet I
know some Chinese guys that would close
this shop if they thought he was coming
in there in my neighborhood